all right audience questions I am
finding that I'm getting better at
picking some of these lately I'm having
a better sense of what is the audience
actually interested in we had a lot of
duds early on okay the question of my
fault of course not anybody else's poor
selection the first question today could
Trump voters be convinced to vote for
someone like Bernie or Warren if Bernie
or Warren went were the nominees there's
always like two if not three answers to
these is it possible question the first
is of course it's possible some
Democrats voted for Trump so in a sort
of general abstract sense yes there are
Trump voters who would be convinced
about
to vote for Bernie or Warren and many of
them would just do it without needing to
be convinced merely because they're not
pleased with Donald Trump some fraction
of them now what is the real philosophy
that would be the most cleanly
transitional one from being a Trump
voter in 2016 to a Bernier Warren voter
in 2020 I think that it is populism now
it's really important I have no
confusion that the populistic rhetoric
of Donald Trump is number one bogus but
number two it's a right-wing rhetoric is
a more nationalist rhetoric nationalist
populist rhetoric it is not at all the
same thing as the Left progressive
rhetoric certainly of Bernie Sanders and
to some degree of Elizabeth Warren
but the messaging at least at the
superficial level can seem quite similar
between Trump's foe right populism and
Bernie and Warren's actual left populism
so there is no doubt that if you were
attracted to Trump in 2016 on the basis
of his populistic ish I mean it's such a
I'm hedging it's not populist it's
populistic ish sort of rhetoric then
there is actually a sort of credible
path to get over to somebody like Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and in fact
anecdotally we heard about Bernie
primary supporters who ended up voting
for Trump which I was a Bernie primary
supporting supporter in 16 I think it
would have been absolutely wacked
to support Trump and here we are Trump
having too
Court picks in almost going to war with
like three countries which Hillary
simply would not have done not that I
was a Hillary lover by any means the
problem with like a big picture move
from Trump voters to Bernie or Warren on
policy and philosophy rather than merely
on they're displeased with Trump and
maybe they'll vote for the alternative
is that there is no real coalition
within the American right that fits into
the Bernie Warren thing they're the
right populist rhetoric of 2016 may work
to get some people just but but by sort
of a numbers game to support Bernie or
Warren but we you know it's not like the
evangelical right that ultimately went
for Trump even though early they liked
Cruz and whoever else that's not a
coalition that's going to get behind
Bernie or war and even though I would
make the argument that Bernie and
Warren's
policy is much more in line with what
evangelical Christianity at least claims
to stand for if not actually stands for
um the you know the pro-gun coalition
that ultimately got behind Trump because
he said some stuff about liking guns or
whatever they're not gonna get behind
Bernie or Warren so I think that's the
issue and then the most important thing
to point out is I don't think it's good
strategy to try to win 2020 by
convincing Trump voters from 2016 to
vote for Bernie or Warren or whoever the
Democratic nominee is we saw earlier
this this week that that emmav ashland
clip from earlier this week where emma
interviewed just may be the dumbest
Trump supporter we've ever seen who said
she wouldn't vote for Joe Biden because
of something related to white /black of
referring to race and Biden's a
socialist because he's all about the
money and he's a billionaire none of
that's true but this is what the woman
said it was made abundantly clear that
would have been saying for a year or
more at this point is right as a
strategy for winning elections don't try
to convince Trump is to vote for someone
else just get the half of the people on
the Left who didn't vote last time to
vote you don't have to convince him of
anything other than just to go out and
vote that's much easier than completely
up ending the be beliefs as harebrained
and fact-free as they may be of a lot of
these trumpets today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom /
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blinky it's amazing it's an
for your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink as comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n